[Music]
in marriage Savior news submitted by its
a JK it's a module a woman who's had
affairs with more than 100 men says she
saves their marriages long okay she said
like a marriage saver is she a sex
therapist like oh no it's a fair in the
sense that she exposes how she D their
husbands where her boyfriends were where
how would that see ya saving the
marriage she's like let me give you a
[ __ ] I mean like and then he's like I
miss my wife
right oh she's not fighting you but
she's a she's a yeah yeah I don't know I
was just thinking in the sense of like
if the husband or boyfriend is caught
cheat or like you know they do cross
that line of trust it's kind of like
well I just exposed that your partner
was a terrible person yeah so she is a
financial consultant what her name is
when it she's 47 years old from London
so her husband died 10 years ago and so
since then she has joined illicit
encounters calm where people who are
married go kind of like the specifically
people that are married go on to this
but nobody who was married went on
Ashley Madison just dudes yeah just all
dudes yeah that's what I read Oh crazy
yeah cuz apparently they were they were
bullshitting like they made it seem I
call there's all these hot chicks there
but it was just [ __ ] dudes so guys
were just meeting each other and doing
it they're like well [ __ ] it
I think there's weren't getting any
pings and there's like no yeah I guess I
look shitty so whatever this side is
she's like the only one [ __ ] like all
the users of the akan this was a
different website I'll show you guys
photos this is one earth with her late
husband the guy that died yeah so now
she's a widower uh-huh here's another
photo of em and so now that she's on
illicit encounters she's just having a
blast heaven lots of sex with why should
look younger now men yes good why why
cause her husband died any good yeah
let's dress gives you glow
a lot of work done oh the picture don't
the picture that's her good side can you
tell Oh girls know that stars do tonight
girls no you don't know your that's the
same side she got younger well there
were some unflattering photos oh I'm far
away so I don't know if you're really
drunk and it's like blurry like hot you
don't even have to be drunk just looking
at girls here I'm bar mute I would just
look at her man you don't gotta get too
drunk yeah there's there's black there's
plastics
oh [ __ ] this is Photoshop as I've ever
seen anything okay this might be yeah
that's just completely smooth okay okay
what does she eat vegetables I don't
know dang I don't care what you get
diagnosed with you don't leave that
behind you done oh yeah you [ __ ] up by
dying yeah so I'll tell you about some
of her affairs and she's so giving she's
out here [ __ ] all these guys that are
maybe was receiving she's receiving
that's for sure I hope she's receiving
so you know she is so I'll tell you
about some of her affairs so the first
one we talked about here is a
pharmaceutical tycoon she said he is in
his 50s and has been happily married for
the last 20 years his wife has no
interest in sex she is aware that all
this interest in money but no sex she is
aware that he has affairs but she
doesn't want to know the details she
turns a blind eye to his absent cuz he's
so rich she doesn't care
she's a great know for sure look at this
next thing his big thing is shopping
whenever he's in London our first trip
is always to agent Probert
provocateur to buy the very finest
lingerie we will then go back to his
hotel and try it all out feasting on
wonderful champagne caviar oysters and
fresh strawberries other times he loves
to go to dinner with to the finest
Michelin star rated town restaurants
before going to his hotel for more sex
I'm his little indulgence he enjoys
lavishing me with wonderful things I am
one of several women he sees from the
listen encounters oh wow one another one
is a hedge fund
manager hmm she says he is family's
fabulously wealthy as I would expect
from a very successful City high flyer
again he is happily married the sex died
in his marriage after they had a child
who was handicapped you're not happy
married if you're not [ __ ] bud it's
not that they keep house that happily
married
and your wife is not interested in you
sexually it's like well I'm we're very
happy
yeah or are we not just in a phase where
we can relate cuz these are all like
people in their late 50s they might have
menopause or something right yeah and
then I think that's when women start
getting around a pause actually fifties
but you can still beat it up if they got
menopause right well the women just
don't they don't want it but no we don't
we go yeah that's when the mustache
comes out yeah cuz your hormones are all
just what am I done what have I done oh
my sweet they should have taught you
this and were you guys you could have
told me we thought you knew she says all
his wife's energies going to taking care
of their child and that left little room
for sex he's devoted to his wife and
their child would just needs a little
release every now he's like that [ __ ]
rich and they can't get some help right
you know I mean like this other one is a
high-flying surgeon he travels all over
with high flying [ __ ] flying right I'll
give you quiet thirty thousand feet
there's a surgeon if you think of
British high flying he travels all over
the world treating patients and
attending conferences and I'm his little
[ __ ] hookers
why don't you just become an escort she
pretty much moister his hotel why fake
the phone could be a financial whatever
she was she doesn't need money so she's
not getting paid for sex yeah this is
her fun yeah yeah she is a financial
consultant but they also mentioned that
her husband was like this big-time oil
executive so I'm also dating I'm
assuming that he left her nice nice but
was he a high-flying elite a oh he might
be a little flying
yeah Cephas he might be like crop Dustin
I've never heard low-flying an oil
tycoon or oil boss or oil would you say
executive executive yeah that's huge
yeah
I mean she's loving the life and she
really feels that she's keeping
marriages together because of the fact
that these men are able to have her as
their little release she keeps call
herself a little release easy but she's
a high-flying literally all she want is
that I thought she's looking I don't
understand how come she wants sex and
she's like 55 and all these she's
programmed differently yeah that's weird
which is 55 or 47 47 so she might be
right out the cusp of the mustache
coming out yeah wait Oh thinking 39 get
in a roll coma this one she talks about
how the marriage was saved because of
the whole thing she says but she talked
about all the other ones where she
[ __ ] up marriages is there a day when
in a marriage no I'm good I'm scared
things to you guys is there Dana
marriage we're like me and Nikki were 50
and I'm like no honey gonna shave like
up yes oh yeah my mom never had to do
that my mom and my dad never had to do
that [ __ ] obvious thing you do I have to
teach Nikki how to shave one day my mom
didn't have them okay well you guys are
scaring me what does your mom do with
her mustache she doesn't have a mustache
they all do you probably just bleaches
it she probably knows how to pluck yeah
they just feel like it's another eye
brother if they're to push your eyebrow
no I poke it up I drink so much monster
energy instead I probably won't make it
so it's fine no don't say that
oh yeah drink so many Monster Energy
song when you eat yeah yeah but I'll be
I'll be guys
I think she'll live I think she'll be
fine so she says this really was a
classic situation where the affair did
save the marriage and keep his family
together
my lover had a huge family and his wife
was exhausted looking after all these
kids when he came home from his job in
the city she had no interest in sex he
would stay in town with me some evenings
and we would meet for dinner and sex his
job was an easy cover story his wife was
incredibly jealous and if he had told
her the truth about what was going on
she would have divorced him causing
terrible damage to the children he was
able to let off steam and keep the
family together perhaps his wife would
had an inkling of what was going on
because one night he came home and she
was waiting for him with the bottle
champagne wearing the most tantalizing
lingerie she had decided it was time to
put the spark back in their marriage and
he had decided it was time to wash his
dick with his marriage review and
because he was just [ __ ] this chick
he's like oh um you wanna [ __ ] my now Oh
wha let me go to the bathroom real quick
yeah I don't know how she I don't feel
like she had anything to do with that
marriage saving no the wife started to
feel the distance yeah yeah I don't I
don't
yeah her story I don't get it this chick
paints a lot and a lot of bright colors
for herself
yeah she's her number one fan yeah oh
yeah obviously cuz she takes a lot of
pictures on her good side well she was
she I forgot to mention Shu is an
ex-model so that that's maybe why she
takes all these photos uh-huh
because it sounds like all the husbands
and stuff that are seeing her little odd
seeing their little release like they
could be paying more attention to their
family and helping their wives and in
like because it seems like they're over
like overworked wives and then they're
just like out like I gotta work late
tonight honey like there's eight kids
that's a quite saw my dream come true
that's what what is just in a day is
they extra day extra for yourself
yeah you're hard worker wipes it home
with eight kids that's [ __ ] up you're
working your ass off to keep this family
funded well you shouldn't have had eight
[ __ ] kids no I'm saying you
want to pass on your genes give eight
times yo and make sure it gets out there
because there's cholera there's disease
is war back in a twenty what you're
looking that's like an Oregon Trail [ __ ]
I pop a lot of kids out but I'm just
like I get tired of taking care of them
can I just like leave you guys in the
will I'll fake my death you guys take
care of the kids and I call this [ __ ]
I'll give you my money what about your
wife the mother yeah I'll give you guys
[Music]
[Music]